en verre bien ouais si jean-louis murat
au cinéma le chanteur à succès nous fait
son premier n'avait plus tomates et
passe à table à une thèse il castagne
monsieur campagne aujourd'hui il y aura
bon soir alors qu'elle a longtemps été
star d'une petite troupe de happy few
et puis ça complètement éclatée avec
xian automne bel air pour la vendu
combien je veux être soixante mille
c'est bien c'est dit une fois on est
vraiment soi même que dans le silence
ouvert depuis tranquille ça c'est une
valeur des gens de la campagne valeurs
paysannes de l'heure de la campagne
et moi je me sens assez bien là-dedans
simple seulement pêche pas d'être une
pipelette quand même mais je préférerais
souvent me taire souvent je regrette ce
que j'ai dit à l'auvergne et pascal
louis entre autres ses pieds à la wii
ces prêts sont pas mal oui mais à force
de dans les interviews force de
je dis toujours que je vienne l'auvergne
pour les parisiens c'est un désert
culturel j'en sais quoi et c'est pour ça
donc j'étais j'essaie toujours un peu
d'encre et l'auvergne dans des choses
très très forte c'est un peu une force
tellurique de l'auvergne avec certains
écrivains on retrouve toujours la même
rigueur un coût des jansénistes moi je
me sens bien la demande
doyon et auvergnats non mais il pourrait
l'être alors tu viens faire ton premier
film avec lui s'appelle la vengeance
d'une femme avec isabelle huppert et
béatrice dalle
toi tu joue le rôle de stéphane